Which are the acts which are allowed
during Itikaf?
The acts which are permitted during
Itikaf that if a need arises
a person can go out of the mosque as
mentioned earlier
either relieve himself or to wash or to
go to the toilet or to the bathroom or
if there's no food etc.
as
the Hadith of Aisha narrated by the
prophet
she says in
Sahih Bukhari
volume number three in the book of
Itikaf Hadith number 2029 that the
prophet while doing Itikaf never entered
the house unless there was a need.
The things which are otherwise permitted
during Itikaf is a person can eat and
drink and sleep
in the mosque.
He can eat and drink and sleep in the
mosque but he should be careful that he
should maintain the sanctity and
maintain the cleanliness of the mosque
because it's a place of worship.
A person
can even comb their hair.
He can oil his hair.
He can remove
the unwanted hair from the body.
He can cut his nails.
He can do Wudu. He can wash. He can have
a bath. He can wear new clothes. He can
put perfume.
These things are permitted.